au moins quatre frappes de drones
kamikaze recensé ce matin dans la
capitale
ukrainienne de fait c'est la première
fois que kif et la cible d'une attaque
coordonnée de drone kamika sur son
soldat des des quartiers
non-résidentiels mais aussi dans des
quartiers résidentiels des images qui
nous parviennent au compte-goutte
d'immeubles en feu ou les secours sont
toujours à l'oeuvre je parlais ce matin
avec d'achat qui a grandi dans la
capitale qui vit encore et qui me disait
et bien voilà une semaine tout juste
après les frappes coordonnées de la
Russie sur la totalité de notre
territoire on se retrouve à nouveau dans
la capitale dans des abris entières elle
nous dit on vient tout juste d'en sortir
enfin pour pouvoir reprendre je cite
cette vie normale/ anormal de fait dans
tout le pays des frappes ont été
recensés cette nuit et tôt ce matin à
zapporijah nous nous trouvons nous avons
entendu pas moins de 9 frappes vers à 4
heures du matin sans savoir si elles ont
touché des infrastructures militaires
les autorités nous ont juste communiqué
que aucun blessé n'était à recenser dans
le sud toujours les forces armées
ukrainiennes affirment avoir neutralisé
au moins 26 drones kamikazes alors que
trois d'entre eux ont touché ont frappé
la ville de mikolaïve alors c'est frappe
c'est bombardements et ses frappes de
drones interviennent dans un contexte
particulier celui d'une contre-offensive
de la part de l'armée ukrainienne dans
le sud autour de Helsen mais également
dans l'est de l'Ukraine dans l'Est ou
les forces russes progressent autour de
la ville stratégique de barmouth